welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
shared the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen
I am Priyanka Vergara and in this
episode we will talk about creating
server less websites on Google cloud
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine you're a small company that got
really big really quickly and now you're
seeing a lot of traffic on your simple
website but you don't want to deal with
the infrastructure setup and maintenance
when you could be focusing on your core
business so let's walk through how not
to worry about the infrastructure setup
for your website by deploying it on
managed server list platform like cloud
run if you would like to deploy on App
Engine instead there is a link in the
description just for you cloud run is a
managed compute platform that
automatically scales stateless
containers stateless is important here
since container instances can be started
or stopped at any time these containers
can be invoked by web requests or
pub/sub events cloud run is also server
less it abstracts of eight all the
infrastructure management so you can
focus on what matters most building
great applications so let's see how to
build a website with cloud run first our
setup logistics identify or create a GCP
project that you would like to use make
sure that the billing is enabled enabled
the cloud run and cloud built api's if
you don't have the Google Cloud SDK
installed today's your day go ahead and
get that ok back to our example at the
time of this recording cloud run is in
beta so we are going to install the beta
components of the Google Cloud SDK using
G cloud components installed beta
command and then we will update the
components this may take a few minutes
to deploy you can use any web app of
your choice for the purpose of this demo
we will create a hello world web
application in Python and then deploy it
using cloud run create a directory using
mkdir hello world and CD into it then
create a file named app dot py and paste
this code into it this code creates a
basic web server that listens on the
ports defined by
court environment variable now we are
ready to containerize our app and upload
to container registry for that we need
to create a new file called docker file
in the same directory as the source
files here we define the official Python
image copy the local code to the
container image installed production
dependencies and a command to run the
web service on container startup now we
are ready to build using cloud built by
running the build command from the
directory containing the docker file
g-cloud builds submit with tag GC r dot
io / project ID / service name I'm just
calling it HelloWorld you will see
success when the build is successful to
deploy the container image we now need
to run g-cloud beta run deploy image
with the image named GC r dot io /
project ID / service name platform
managed when prompted to select the
region choose one through US central one
provide a service name of your choice
and respond with the yes to allow
unauthenticated invocations on success
we see the service URL we can visit our
website by opening that in our web
browser congratulations we have just
deployed a web application packed in
container image on cloud run cloud run
automatically and horizontally scales
your container image to handle the
received request then scales back down
when the demand decreases you only pay
for the CPU memory and networking
consumed during request handling so
today we learnt a second recipe for
deploying of have application on google
cloud we created and deployed a dynamic
web application on cloud run and learnt
that if you host a web site on cloud run
you can rely on Google cloud for it to
scale with the demand that's all for
today on get cooking in cloud here's
hoping you
whip up something great join us next
time because we will share the recipe to
host websites on compute engine if you
like this video and check out the
previous episodes - and to see more such
content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]